sometimes these movements have to be
driven by people who are true believers
because what happens is they they push
things all the way over and then it
comes back americans are not an extreme
people
we are not extreme americans are not
socialists
americans are not super right wing
americans want a better life for their
kids for the most part
and are too busy with with with their
everyday thing i got to take my kid to
baseball and i want to be able to afford
after school activities for my kids
that's what they really care about
i want a little extra cash
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys click that
subscribe button
and that little notification bell so you
have a small chance at least
of cnr videos and joining me today is a
comedian
and actor and co-host of the fighter in
the kid podcast
brian callan welcome to the reuben
report thank you sir
big fan big fan love it big fan here i
am
i finally made it you're in the internet
now i'm i'm
this is like the center of this
yes this right here everything that we
say here stays here no one will get in
any trouble
you're exactly fine as long as you uh as
long as you don't
express yourself freely and thoughtfully
and with reason
that seems like a good place to start
yeah comedy in an age of cancellation
how you feeling these days
i think that it feels as though this is
the last
bastion for satire honest expression
original self-expression
you know i've had comics call me and say
well i've got the show with a certain
network and i'm afraid that what i
said uh i expressed a point of view that
was more
complicated than some black or white no
pun intended yeah
you know oh you're going for it already
and uh should i
should i do this you you have comics now
wondering if they should edit themselves
in podcasts and my answer is if
that is what if if you are
um worried about that because you're
working for that network then you
shouldn't work for that network then
you're no longer a comic
then you're no longer in the business of
original self-expression
thoughts and art has always been there
to disturb
to shake things up let's take will and
grace
as an example i auditioned for that show
maybe five times i can't remember if it
was for jack
it was for eric it was for both and i
knew it was going to be a hit
but it was so groundbreaking it was so
astonishing it was the first time that
gay people were
kind of highlighted as this um as
people with senses of humor who wanted
the same thing that straight people want
i remember that being a radical
new uh idea
and it you know back then you know we
always talk about how you can get
canceled for certain words you say well
in the um well let's say all through all
of american history
up through probably the 90s
if you were found out to be gay in a in
the workplace
well if you didn't get fired you weren't
going to get promoted it was a
major liability and physically dangerous
so along comes will and grace
and a network took a risk so in that
sense
you know you can you can point to
examples where it's very important to
continue to speak your mind
and it's very important when the
pendulum swings
too far right or too far left or too far
in any direction as an artist you got to
push back
you got to kind of go you got to make
fun of it and that's the one
through all this insanity and there are
a lot of bad ideas out there and there
are a lot of sort of like
um these were very polarized there's no
room for nuance as you know
as i'm sure you've picked up on but um i
do think americans
have this really great safety valve this
switch which is humor
we tend to make fun of ourselves we tend
to make fun of
of canceled culture already we tend to
make fun of
of all these things there's
trump is always being made fun of and so
is the other side so i think
at least we are going to always
we'll always have that thing
even kids now my friend's son who is
16. my his my buddy said
look at that look at that butterfly i
wonder what he's gonna
land on next and his friend said dad
how are you assuming that's a he i mean
how do you know
and already kids are making fun of this
stuff yeah
so i think that's very healthy but
doesn't this seem a little unique in
that there's like a runaway train
aspect to it right now where it used to
be kind of like oh
one person randomly said one thing and
they get taken out where now it just
feels like the whole track got destroyed
the train is going off and everyone's
kind of going with it at the same time
if we were
if this was 1968 we'd be saying the same
thing
and we'd be even more panicked you know
um
i think right now we're dealing with a
confluence of events
yeah you're dealing with you know the
george floyd the terrible
murder of george floyd you're dealing
with covet 19 where nobody has jobs
nobody has anywhere to go to uh and
you're dealing with all these
uncertainties and you're dealing with
this incredibly polarizing figure
named donald trump so that all of that
stuff i think
is a perfect storm so it's when you're
in it it's hard to see
a way out of it and it's hard to see
sense i do think again
there are a lot of bad ideas out there
and i do think that um
but again if i'm a moderate person i
just
am i'm naturally moderate yeah medium
yeah
uh well when i was on your show we were
trying to figure out what we might
differ on politically we couldn't come
up with that
no i think you're a very reasonable i've
listened to you many times
and i and i've listened to your guests
and you're you know the truth is you are
a reasonable fair-minded person
don't tell that to the new york times
well yeah you know again
i think and then i i find myself saying
you know um sometimes these movements
have to be driven by people who are true
believers
because what happens is they they push
things all the way over and then it
comes back americans are not an extreme
people
we are not extreme americans are not
socialists
americans are not super right wing
americans
want a better life for their kids for
the most part and are too busy
with with with their everyday thing
i got to take my kid to baseball and i
want to be able to afford after school
activities for my kids that's what they
really care about
i want a little extra cash i mean if you
really come down to it
and i think that they the silent
majority
the most they ever really do is write
letters
tweet we tweet now come on you know
stuff like that but but but
you know come election time a lot of
times if
if if they feel like their bottom line
is being affected
i.e the way their children are being
raised educated
and uh and and whether or not they have
a little extra cash in their pocket
that'll get them to the polls yeah
otherwise
i got enough for this and i got enough
for that yeah i want to stick with the
comedy thing for a little bit because
you mentioned how if you're a comic and
you're working at a network that's
making you sense or making you question
yourself then you're working at the
wrong place
yes isn't it odd though that for all of
us that are now in the podcast youtube
whatever you want to call this thing
that now we're watching ourselves do it
to ourselves
we're our own bosses i'm not saying
you're doing it and i'm not doing it
but we know a lot of people now that are
getting in trouble because of what's
being said
on podcasts and we know that you know
media matters watches every word
yeah that somebody's going to say so
that if you know anybody says one thing
the wrong way
but you're gonna take them out even
though these guys own their stuff yeah
um but trouble when you say getting in
trouble the truth is
that um they're not the truth is that i
i look at getting in trouble as not
being able to earn a living
uh you know um corporations are
incredibly
in many ways spineless and we'll get
into that in a second
and what i mean by that but but um i
think that
you're still look i'm on stage all the
time i was in arizona i was in texas
um anywhere i go when i
when i say things that seem reasonable
when i criticize
the s sort of even whether it's
conservatives or liberals and i can i
criticize both people love it
people clap people laugh because uh
typically i think i always find that if
i'm feeling this way
so is most of the country because most
people are
they're just reasonable they're not
indoctrinated into an
ideology if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell